all right joining me now with reaction
Congressman Jim Jordan ranking member of
the House Oversight Committee
congressman let's start on the border
issue then we're gonna get back to what
else is cooking but I mean we're gonna
talk about this later but this is a
national travesty and the Democrats will
say oh it's it's it's not bad at all on
the border it's it's and you know
interceptions that people are down there
are fewer people crossing what's the
real truth just heard from the agents on
the border talking about how about is
even the New York Times talked about the
77,000 just this month alone crossing
the border so I always say if what are
we on the fifth Caravan what do we need
a six caravan seventh Caravan and
endless caravan before we say it's an
emergency the president is right and
some of them the Republicans who are
opposing the president as you said in
your in your opening in your Ingraham
angle some of those are the same ones
who last year during the Congress didn't
want to get it done when we had the
majority in both the House and the
Senate so this is something that's gonna
looks like the Senate's gonna vote to
overrule the president's order but when
the president vetoes and it comes back
for veto we'll be able to sustain Mitch
McConnell could have pushed this
demanded his we should have done the
last slice of Congress but they promised
the president you're gonna get your wall
funding just get us through this period
don't that isn't that always a little
carrot you dangle and friends I'm right
right we'll get it later there there's
always a million reasons why you
shouldn't do what you said you would do
most importantly what you what the
voters elected you to do but this
president is is keeping his word and
doing what he said that's why the
American people like him and that's why
this town doesn't like your advice to
him
in this moment well we're gonna get into
the impeachment yes squad people oh we
got them the walls are closing around
umpire we got these subpoenas issued
exact Jared you know some weird Russians
I've never heard like oh they're all
named and the 81 people what should the
president do this is swirling around
just keep doing his job I was back home
Friday night we had the Lincoln Day
dinner I spoke at and the crowd was huge
and they were so enthusiastic for for
the president fighting for what he told
the American people to do you know
what's interesting too about these 81
letters that mr. Nadler sent what's
interesting is who he didn't send him to
he didn't send all these people 80 81
different entities over 60 different
people but he didn't send it to the two
most important Glenn Simpson and
Christopher Steele Glenn Simpson it was
paid by the Clintons to put the dossier
together and who do
he hired Christopher Steele a foreigner
to write the dossier that was the base
of all that's the line about all those
people but not the two that count the
most and so look they started their
impeachment effort last Wednesday they
started their impeachment last Wednesday
with Michael Cohen and Michael Cohen
their first announced witness of the
116th Congress a guy who's going to
prison in two months for lying to
Congress came in last Wednesday and did
their ace in the hole came in last
Wednesday did what lied six times under
oath and that's why we sent a criminal
referral letter to the Attorney Bill's
bar bill bar has got to act on this I'm
sorry bill bar could act on this could
bill bar reopen the investigation into
mrs. Clinton he could he
what what he should do is tell us what
John Huber's doing what Michael Horowitz
is doing what what the FISA abuse that
they're supposed to be looking into and
this whole idea that you had the top
people at the FBI Comey McCabe Baker's
struck page all these people who
launched and ran the Clinton
investigation and then launched and ran
the Trump Russia investigations they've
all been fired or left the FBI two are
under investigation that's where we need
to look there's plenty of collusion here
right but what about the Tony Podesta
why does he seem to be able to get away
with so much so much this activity was
right we've talked about this before and
you've been great on this this double
standard one set of rules for us regular
folk a different set but now we have a
new Attorney General in place so it
could take dispassionate look we're not
no one's looking to put scalps on the
wall but if this is what we're going to
be dealing with like on the other side
at least people should have a clear
sense of what happened before this
correct right go go go back and look at
this fundamental fact the Clinton
campaign paid the law firm Perkins
Cooley who hired Glenn Simpson who then
went and hired a foreigner Christopher
Steele who talked to a couple Russians
never went to Russia put together this
fake document called the dossier that
the FBI use manipulate a cave in all
these piano use struck and pages used to
go to a secret court to get a warrant to
spy on the Trump campaign and that's
what launched it all and now we've got
81 left for the people but none of them
are going to the guys account the most
Christopher Steele and Glen Sampson I
think everyone who signed those FISA
warrants those applications to the court
not revealing that it was Hillary
Clinton who paid for them
still sticks in my craw here's the other
thing we have we got competing testimony
we got McCabe saying one thing Comey
saying something else struck saying one
thing hey this is this is why we need to
look at this issue and nobody because oh
this is what drives people crazy it does
we have a new attorney general who is a
prawn summit professional we're gonna
talk to you about these things and you
you are in the process of talking them
about all this we are I know we'll say
oh that's looking backward we want to
look for no no this is the rule of law
rule of law equal treatment under the
law most importantly congressman thank
you so much for joining us tonight we
really appreciate it